[Musique]
dames ont pensé qu'il était utile
d'éclairer au maximum les citoyennes et
des citoyens sur un phénomène qui
est palpable même temps qui est rarement
débattu celui de la concentration dans
les médias c'est à dire le fait que des
grands groupes de plus en plus possède
dans son média avec ce paradoxe il ya de
plus en plus d'offres médiatique le
support de titres etc donc on a
l'impression de diversité gigantesque
mais de plus en plus un petit nombre de
propriétaires possèdent l'ensemble de
ces médias ont fait des propositions sur
maintenir un niveau élevé de qualité de
l'information
protéger le métier de journaliste revoir
la loi de 86 parce que tout le monde se
dit qu elle reconnaît qu'elle est
obsolète a essayé de mieux mesurer
justement l'impact du numérique
notamment sur la prise en compte de
l'audience revoir les aides à la presse
bref toutes ces questions enfin tous ces
points toutes ces propositions qui sont
qui sont fondamentales et que nous avons
essayé de
établir dans ce rapport je pense que ce
document sera une référence pour tous
ceux qui veulent travailler sur la
question de la concentration des médias
ces dangers avoir avoir de la matière
pour se faire une opinion et
et quand on élève le niveau de
connaissances et d'intelligence on devra
la démocratie et donc si seulement cet
objectif avait été remplie il me
suffirait